I was like pretty happy at Google but I
felt like I could be like happier doing
something else
so I hope you don't mind me asking for
like so how much do you make with CS
though Jonelle so it's kind of tricky
because it goes up and down a little bit
okay but I would say the average for the
past few months has been about ten
thousand US dollars per month nice yeah
before we continue this video I just
want to say that this video is sponsored
by Goku now dotco domains are dope
they're pretty much the hottest domains
like for example Vine Co now if you
watch my startup series you would know
that I have a startup called not vine
so I actually wanted to get not vine dot
cope because I really wanted to mimic
vine Co unfortunately when I check the
website it wasn't available someone took
it before me I wonder if they watch my
series but basically if they took it
before me and unfortunately can't get
that but I was able to get revine Co by
the way revine is basically my nemesis
startup which is exactly the same as not
mine I haven't fully decided what to do
with it yet but I'm pretty sure that
it's gonna be something video related
either I can just have it as an alias
for kinda like my portfolio for all my
videos or I can have like a user
submitted video platform that I can make
we'll see we'll see
anyways back to Coco so Coco is a place
to find Co domains and like I said Co is
pretty dope
Co is basically like dot IO but way
cooler like dot IO I just so
old-fashioned it's not cool anymore
nobody uses that anymore
it's all about kono all the hottest
startups usko for example like I said
fine coal and there's other ones like
Angel Co Rico Berko these are all like
super dope companies they have over 2.2
million domains registered worldwide
it's short so you can easily type it on
your phone
memorable so if you have a start-up it's
a very unique name for your brand which
is very useful for a start-up so if you
want to register a dot codomain go to go
code and register your domain now and
then also build something with it I
can't wait to see what you guys build
all right so welcome I usually don't
like talk to the camera anymore I Drive
to you yeah pretty much
favorite question yeah so anyways yeah
so you want to just give a little
introduction to like my viewers and
stuff like that like for example your
name your channel and stuff like sure
yeah just real all right I guess I'm
we're not talking to the camera if you
want yeah yeah whatever
so as you know my name is YK and I've
been running you know my youtube channel
called CS dojo it's a programming
discretion YouTube channel that I've
been running for the past three years
now the first year I did it part-time
you know while I was working at Google
as a software developer and then the
past two years have been a full-time you
know a lot of people ask me like can I
make a living out of it and the answer
is yes I can and that's what I've been
doing cool so yeah I mean honestly I'm
like super impressed that you know you
were able to like quit your job at
Google and then start like YouTube like
pretty much full-time now yes I was
wondering like is like I've seen the
video of why you quit Google but do you
want to just like talk about it again
and the house or even more questions
about it yeah so sure why did you quit
Google and start YouTube right full-time
now yeah full-time and so you know this
is something I already talked about on
this channel I can I you mentioned yeah
but I sort of thought about it again for
this particular interview huh and here's
the way I think about it you know there
are there are sort of two parts to it
the first part was that you know I
wanted to like spend more time on
YouTube get better at you know making
videos and
basically help more people and then the
second part was that I was like pretty
happy at Google but I felt like I could
be like happier doing something else
so maybe like I could going to you know
either of them if you want me to oh yeah
both of them yeah sure
so the YouTube part you know this one I
think there are like two ways of
thinking about it and both of them were
true
the first one is that you know I had
about seven thousand subscribers and
maybe like you know about a hundred
thousand total views at that point like
right before I left Google Wow okay yeah
so it's like it's like it's not like a
lot of views but it's you know it's some
traction that's pretty gutsy cuz like
yeah I went like I would be too afraid
to do it even now from my channel right
yeah I like I was pretty afraid but I
feel like sort of did it uh-huh and you
know I had like a few courses going on
and I was making I don't know like three
hundred four hundred dollars for up
those courses like a month or yeah a
month yeah and basically nothing from
YouTube so what my original idea was
okay if I can make like ten more courses
like that I'll make like three to four K
a month and that's gonna be enough for
like rent and food and everything else
so that that's sort of the financial
plan I had and at the same time I you
know I thought that I would be able to
help a lot more people you know through
my youtube channel time through my job
mm-hmm so that's sort of one way of
looking at it the other way of looking
at it which is also true is that I saw
this business opportunity and I didn't
want to miss it
right all right that makes a lot of
sense yeah okay so I hope you don't mind
me asking for like so how much do you
make with CS dojo now so it's kind of
tricky because it goes up and down a
little bit okay
but I would say the average for the past
few months has been about ten
I US dollars per month nice yeah and
then the breakdown was like 40% yeah
okay that's the same breakdown
yeah well that's pretty cool nice do you
want to make more or like are you okay
with that no I'm happy with it you know
like I said earlier I want to be able to
stabilize my income a little bit more
but I don't see any reason to like make
more because I like I can do everything
on my own like anything shooting
anything cool awesome yeah but like it's
crazy how you validated this business
opportunity just with like your YouTube
channel because you know a lot of the
times when you hear about startups they
always talk about okay you build an MVP
yeah I validate your idea and then you
go all in so can you kind of say that
your YouTube channel when it was only
7000 subscribers that was already an MVP
yeah that was that was one of the MVPs I
had okay were you ever scared that like
oh maybe it won't grow anymore yeah like
at the top yeah I was like I was
actually super scared on till like maybe
like six months in so like I left Google
two years ago in April May something
like that uh-huh and then I think if I
remember correctly in August or
September of the same year like you know
six months after I quit my job I was
making like $1,000 a month and I was
like I like I just make a lot more than
I'm making yeah but like I just as a kid
you know I just like going like what was
like the biggest polling factor was it
that oh there's like a big business
opportunity yeah or was it like oh I
really want to help a lot north but with
like I would say equally equally
important for the business opportunity
like were you more motivated by like how
much money potentially can you get or
okay so not like not the amount of money
okay I would say it's more about the
sort of the stability that comes from
being a business owner
because when you're an employee no
matter how good the company is there's
always a risk of you know either being
laid off or being fired right and like I
don't see Google doing that anytime soon
but it's possible I came 10 20 years so
I thought like by having a business you
know my financial situation will be like
stable in the long term basically that's
very funny cuz like most people when
they don't want to go you know start
your own business or start your own
startup is because they have more
financial stability right in a company
yeah I'm very surprised that you're
actually thinking like the yeah yeah
it's it's it's a funny way of thinking
about it but the way I think about it is
you know in the short term it's
obviously more stable do you have a job
in the long term mmm-hmm I mean my
business is still pretty unstable but if
I have like two or three businesses I
don't have to like rely on you know why
don't them - I got it yeah yeah so so
like when I made those videos back then
I was definitely making you know a lot
less money I would say I don't remember
exactly but I think it was like - 3k a
month you know but now it's like
comparable to what I used to make it
what you used to me okay yeah so can't
tell me Martha like the all the Brethren
court like all the sources of being sure
that you get which one's the biggest you
know yeah that if ever you guys want to
do it yeah try it or they can at least
know how it goes
yeah of course so I guess the first
thing I would say about that is that
it's really tough yeah you know doing
the other doing business on YouTube but
for me at the breakdown I think is about
like I would say 40 to 45 percent
YouTube ad revenue 40 to 50 or 40 to 45
percent like stuff like that yeah
it is not the exact number but that's
sort of the you know rough number yeah
and then the rest is my courses and you
know affiliate marketing mmm
next sponsorships I did a little bit but
you know it's not it's not an ongoing
payment
okay sponsorship meaning like a flat
rate right okay yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty funny cuz like for me to add
revenue is very little I think it's
probably like maybe 20 percent okay yeah
and then everything else is just a flat
rate sponsorships right I just started
doing the affiliate link recently yeah
with elbow expertise and I actually use
the other one too that you use which is
daily coding a problem yeah use my promo
code if you want to so yeah and yeah so
far it seems like that's okay too but
yeah like for me I just do like a lot of
flat rate sponsorships and and yet those
ones are pretty good so far
the are you thinking that you might
expand in terms of monetization how yeah
so for monetization I'm happy where I am
income because I'm at a point where you
know I can basically afford my rent and
food and everything else and that's
basically why I need a cut but you know
content wise yeah I'm still thinking
about it I was thinking maybe like more
interview kind of videos or podcasts or
maybe going into machine learning as
yeah yeah yeah how that makes sense
I remember you making a video about
quantum computers yeah yeah like are you
interested in like the the most novel
tech and stuff like that no no no no not
necessarily